first we're the only party at this
election which can show how every policy
in our manifesto will be paid for no
commitments requiring additional
borrowing not a single one this is the
first lot second our manifesto writes
the first line of Labor's first budget
this budget cuts the deficit every year
and that budget will only be presented
when that has been verified by the
Office of Budget Responsibility that is
the second look third the next Labour
government will meet our fiscal rules
with the national debt falling and a
surplus on the current budget so we'll
set new ambitions for the minimum wage a
minimum wage by 2019 reaching its
highest ever proportion of average
earnings rising to more than 8 pounds an
hour so hard work pays again in our
country and we write the next chapter in
the fight to end low pay
we will legislate so everyone who works
regular hours will get a regular
contract not a zero hours contract the
next Labour government will introduce a
new national childcare service to work
with primary schools to help guarantee
that wrap around childcare that should
be there for every working parent that
wants it we will not raise national
insurance or v18 or the basic or higher
rates of income tells we'll say enough
is enough to the people who live here
work here send their kids to school here
but don't want to pay taxes here like
everyone else and we will abolish the
non dog
rule our plan will freeze energy bills
so they can only fall and cannot rise
and give the regulator at the power to
cut prices this winter we will champion
small and medium-sized firms and cut and
freeze business rates for one and a half
million companies will guarantee
apprenticeships to every young person
who gets the grades and will do
something else will make amends for the
mistakes of this government for the
betrayal of young people for calamity
clegg and we'll cut tuition fees from
nine thousand to six thousand pounds
that's why it's right to ask those who
can to pay a little bit more with the
crackdown on tax avoidance a
the tobacco companies and a mansion tax
are the most expensive properties with
over 2 million pounds
it's a properly costed fully funded plan
for twenty thousand more nurses eight
thousand more doctors five thousand more
home care workers and 3,000 more
midwives that is the rescue plan that
our National Health Service means we'll
call time on David Cameron's
privatisation of the NHS with a cap on
private profit in our health service and
we will do something else
we will abolish we will repeal their
terrible Health and Social Care Act and
put the right values back at the heart
of our National Health Service those who
come to our shores from abroad should
make their contribution to our country
before they claim benefits people should
learn English if they work directly with
the public in our public services and we
must never allow the wages of working
people to be driven down by the gang
masters the rogue employers and those
who avoid paying the minimum wage
because this Labor Party will always
fight exploitation wherever we find it
more powers for the Scottish Parliament
more powers for the Welsh Assembly and
to the cities towns and counties of
England - it's time to end a century of
centralization throughout our United
Kingdom
it's time to extend the right to vote to
16 and 17 year old so young people can
have a proper voice in our country